martin biron josée legault michèle dawe
et de bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir on reparle
de délestage aujourd'hui un journal de
montréal la une ce matin dans la presse
d'autres exemples déchirant nous on
avait maïka cas tant pour les deux
genoux pour lui dire la seule façon
aller au privé et 25000 dollars
je veux entendre ce que monsieur dubé a
répondu à ça aujourd'hui et on revient
pas la bonne nouvelle c'est que on au
moins éliminer la la progression qu'on
est en train de faire le compte on
arrivait à 15 cents hospitalisation
d'être revenu à peu près mille deux cent
cinquante mais l'on peut commencer
en ce moment replanifier de reprendre
certaines opérations
ce qu'on pouvait même pas pensé il ya
deux semaines vous allez voir je passais
vendredi ou lundi qu'on va donner
certaines directives à nos amours pdg
pour commencer à replanifier des
chirurgies mais qui va tenir compte des
particularités dans certaines régions
d'un bon martin ont dit on va rouvrir un
peu ma chaîne
on va redonner des salles d'opération
entre autres sortent au p 10 mais là on
parlé au docteur nguyên tout à l'heure
c'est grave
il ya beaucoup de monde qui souffre oui
le plan martin et c'est flou c'est très
flou on en utilise un moore planifié
mais quand on la question était posée au
ministre
qu'en pensez vous que les salles
d'opération vont pouvoir ouvrir et était
capable de répondre évidemment le format
des points de presse
ed paul on s'est assez
limité comme question on peut
difficilement faire d'eux des relances
mais ça va devenir un embarras pour le
gouvernement quand le gros de la
pandémie sera passée il va y avoir des
drames dans beaucoup de familles et des
visages sur les une de nos journaux on
va commencer à mettre des visages sur
les gens c'est comment ça ça commence
alors le gouvernement va être contrée en
fait de votre devoir accélérer les
choses pour trouver une solution sinon
c'est un boulet qui va traîner jusqu'à
la fetwa mandat pourrait josé qu'en
pensez vous de ce problème énorme de
délestage c'est très très très grave et
on en a pour des années à être dans
cette espèce de goulots d'étranglement
qui est en effet banga chez davy engage
déjà et il faut penser aussi à tous les
gens qui non seulement souffre
physiquement mais qui souffrent
financièrement aussi il ya déjà que vous
êtes obligés d'arrêter de travailler les
champions n'ont pas d'assurance déjà
qu'ils vont faire faillite et de tous
les âges là alors c'est très très grave
et moi ce qui me frappe souvent dans les
points de presse que ce soit le premier
ministre le ministre commence toujours
par mes yeux une bonne nouvelle et
toujours cette espèce de d'enveloppés le
garde pas de bonnes nouvelles pour le
moment et on voit que dans le système de
santé les langues aussi commencé à se
délier et là il ya des médecins de plus
en plus de médecins
ça devient tout à l'heure qui parle et
qui disent écoutez non seulement ça
marche pas mais qui eux mêmes ont des
idées pour que ça aille mieux et qu'ils
ne se sentent pas entendus sur mon
stable à 100 les chirurgiens
orthopédistes orthopédique de aimerait
aller davantage au privé envoyer la
facture au public dans les cas vraiment
drôle plus plus urgent que quelqu'un qui
a travaillé toute sa vie michel david a
qui ont audible la seule façon de
comprendre le béton lit c'est si tu
payes 21ème place pour te faire un
remplacer large
il ya quelque chose d'aberrant
oui mais ça c'est le vieux débat la
médecine à deux vitesses dont on a déjà
parlé au québec
abondamment il ya plusieurs années mais
là ça prend ça prend un tour beaucoup
plus dramatique ce débat là est ce qui
m'a frappé dans la réponse de ce que
j'ai remarqué dans la réponse de
monsieur dubé c'est qu'il n'ya pas
évoquer du tout la possibilité d'avoir
recours au privé de dix bons vont
reprendre tranquillement public et
savait déjà été il avait été interpellé
quelques semaines maintenant et à ce
moment là monsieur dubé avait dit ouah
mais le secteur privé un pôle expertise
pour ça
bon je comprends que le secteur privé
peut-être de commander des codes de colo
gilles mais des codes de caumont le
butin tôle avec votre top existe des
cadences de genou au sol le secteur
privé en fait à la tonne alors ça
règlerait pas tout parce que la liste
d'attenté est elle je pense que nick
actuel suffirait pas à résorber sa mai
mais au moins commencer à assumer âge et
je sais pas comment prioriserait les
jeunes mais j'ai maintenant
ouais il provoque habitante orthopédie
depuy dire dans mes 72,14 urgemment ben
voilà on va prendre les plus urgents et
toi et toi mais le ministre a pas ouvert
du tout le cas
mais d'où ma question oui le plein est
ce que il entendit lisent les journaux
il voit les premières pages y lisent nos
bons la souvine skis cas l'air
extraordinaires qu'on ne se présentait
au paternel la semaine dernière l'autre
ya deux semaines ll est en trop en
charge de ce sommet venez nous expliquer
le plan pour les prochains mois le
prochain dès le mois prochain trois mois
surtout j'ai j'ajouterai que ce que
semblait dire monsieur le ministre de la
santé
christian dubé c'est que c'était la même
chose partout dans les régions il
précise que le deux tiers des
hospitalisations sont dans l'eau à
montréal et dans le grand montréal et
que la pression est énorme la mé c
et ça semble est aussi difficile à
québec ou au saguenay ou dans les
hôpitaux de toutes les régions ils
semblaient pas être capable de dire qu'
il est vrai le pied là dans certaines
régions du québec
bon alors on venait mais si je peux
jouer à l'est du jourdain
oui mais si ces médias les suggestions
que concertée médecin s'est pas
seulement aussi d'aller au privé mais
c'est il ya aussi toute une
réaffectation du personnel et ce dont
ils se plaignent aussi c'est que il ya
il ya des infirmières etc qui sont
envoyées continuellement au front de
l'aco vide et qui ne sont pas là là où
elle devrait être
et là où est vraiment leur formation
donc c'est ça mais je le répète dans la
cellule de crise
il serait peut-être temps après dix mois
qui a du sang neuf et puis qu'on laisse
rentrer un petit peu d'air frais parce
que je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
fatigue
oui en tout cas on va espérer contrôle
des solutions parce que ces dix grammes
encore une fois c'est pas des malaises
ton contrat quelque chose qui n'est pas
urgent on se dit on est en guerre il ya
une pandémie très bien on atteint n'est
ce pas de ça dont on parle tous les cas
qui ressortent c'est des gens qui sont
sérieusement atteints et qui dans un
système entre guillemets moderne public
devrait être vu celle d'avesnes qui est
aussi il ya des cliniques privées
actuellement qui font toutes sortes
d'opérations esthétiques qui sont
vraiment pas urgente
je comprends que ces gens là peut-être
pas capable de faire une opération mais
il ya certainement des interventions qui
lui qui brille présente un caractère
beaucoup plus urgent qu'il est une
chirurgie esthétique qui pourra faire et
là je pense que le gouvernement doit les
intrus
très bien ou qui pourraient prêter leurs
locaux prêtés leurs locaux puis vous
avez raison je ne sais pas que le privé
qui est pas la panacée que pas tant de
place mais on a quand même bien mais
qu'ils vont recevoir grosse facture qui
vont aller puis pourquoi ces gens
l'opéra dans un très bref le monsieur
legault par ailleurs le message
aujourd'hui c'est à dire compte tenu que
les hospitalisations sont encore très
élevés
ne pensez pas que le 8 février l'on va
débloquer tous appuyé que s'est terminé
le couvre-feu on va écouter monsieur
legault revient on voit pour le 8
février faire certain assouplissement
mais je veux être très clair il faudra
être réaliste
la majeure partie des mesures de
confinement vont rester ça soit pas
juste à montréal le couvre-feu le
couvre-feu va donc maintenant l'annoncé
afin de prêcher autres adjugé 2 février
mais ce que c'est possible que les
impossibles c'est très possible et la
terre attac idée d'en mourir les
salamandres y vend des réponses à cette
prochaine mais effectivement nos quais
voudrait pocket roda temps ça résume
bien la michel d'un bijou sera pas qu'un
trop d'attentes
non c'est clair que ça pour le
couvre-feu a nettement patrie j'ai
l'impression c'est la mesure qui était
le moins contesté les gens s'y sont
pliés je pense le gouvernement est lui
même surpris de la bonne grâce avec
laquelle les gens se sont conformés et
dans cette mesure là je pense qu'il ya
pas de grosse pression pour lever ce
parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus de pression
de du côté des restaurants des débats et
ça je doute que ça soit ouvert même où
la pandémie beaucoup moins grande
là où on pourrait peut-être espérer
des ouvertures c'est dans les trucs
comme les coiffeurs par exemple ou des
soucis à l'e-commerce certain nombre de
commerces à mais dans des endroits qui
présentent un moindre risque et qu'ils
présentent comme andy représentant
caractère semi essentiel mais des
consignes mans plus général de monsieur
legault très certainement pour pour
monter les attentes
sinon ces singes aux essais stackler
qu'il voulait dire le 8 février
l'oublier cette date butoir
tout ne va pas redevenir plus souple
dans les régions y voir des changements
notre montréal québec se vont être pas
mal pareil oui mais même dans les
régions il faut être extrêmement prudent
parce qu'on veut pour revivre version
hyper ce qu'on a vécu l'été dernier
c'est à dire où les montréalais sont
rués deir al balah dans les régions et
il pouvait devenir l'un des vecteurs de
propagation donc c'est très délicat tout
ça pour le couvre-feu ben c'est la
psychologie humaine de base c'est là
même dont on discutait l'an dernier pour
le masquer un temps que sap a été
imposée tant qu'ils avaient pas des
menaces d'amande et bien c'est que ça
reste une minorité des gens qui le
portait du jeu pendant les lieux publics
clos et le couvre-feu c'est la même
chose c'est une mesure très dur c'est
une mesure très contraignantes qui à des
amendes et là maintenant enfin grâce à
la cour supérieure du québec
les personnes itinérantes en sont
exemptés mais écoutez si vous le faites
vous payez peau ouais martin d'hères une
parenthèse sur les itinérants sur
legault lors du point de presse d'hier
quelques jours avait laissé voir son
agacement qu'on le critique est là
dessus il se l'est fait quand même assez
dire clairement par la course et si ça
marche pas cette histoire là pour des
gens qui vivent dans la rue match un peu
en fait monsieur legault a décidé de
donner suite au jugement de la cour
supérieure et les billets qui ont déjà
été données
les itinérants devrait être
excusez je voudrais juste donné dire un
petit mot sur le maintien du couvre feu
parce que j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement crée énormément sur le goût
le dis aussi dans son point de presse
la relâche et si les gens ne voyage pas
l'étranger et craint qu'il voyage d'une
région à l'autre et qui se visitent
finalement une bulle à l'autre et que ça
complique les choses alors il va
peut-être vouloir étendre le couvre-feu
le pour passer cette période là il ya
même dit c'est pas tant de faire garder
vos enfants par les grands parents qui
ont 65 ans et plus et mais ça va quand
même
grenier un peu le jeu d'après midi je
fais des chroniques radio dans les
régions que j'étais avec sept îles et
ils populaire at that couvrions 9 0 k
actif depuis plusieurs jours soumis
alors il va être confronté à celui ci
faire avaler la pilule sur le couvrir ok
on termine avec jean françois roberge y
reste quatre minutes jean françois
roberge ventes entre véronique hivon
parti québécois qui est exaspéré par ce
que le programme de tutorat n'arrive pas
assez vite selon elle puis réponse de
monsieur legault sur le ministre il est
vraiment 23h55
pour jean françois roberge s'est lui en
quelque sorte la bombe ans clément qui
sait si est capable d'arrêter le
détonateur avant qu'elle lui explose en
plein visage c'est vraiment sérieux la
situation
la perte de confiance est importante le
tutorat on en parle depuis le mois de
mai et il n'y a rien qui s'est fait le
souci pédagogique on en parle depuis le
mois de mai on commence aujourd'hui à
ouvrir le site pour 0 gens vous pouvez
appliquer
moche très fier d'avoir jean françois
roberge communiste de l'éducation pense
qu'il ne fait beaucoup depuis qu'il est
là on vit actuellement une crise qui
sans précédent je dois pas avoir
personne d'autre que lui pour gérer ça
maintenant la partie communication qui
est du transfert dans les responsables
attaché de presse et directeur de
communication entre les ministères ce
pôle premiers pas d'arrangement semoule
et que le message passe me vous
connaissez jean-françois del torchio
l'eau qui relève un nouveau défi à
l'éducation et aux ministères importants
jean-françois del torchio qui vient donc
à aider en communication le ministre
quelqu'un qu'on a connus fédéral qui est
au gouvernement avec la vice première
ministre depuis un bout de table celle
david vous en est tous sur le ministre
l'éducation
mais quand on parle commence à parler
d'un problème de communication l'a
nettement généralement qu'un problème de
fond mais quand on veut pas l'admettre
et je pense que monsieur legault je sois
dans un commentaire un esprit de manimal
il ya autre chose à penser ça viendra
mais il va attendre la pandémie que le
gros de la pandémie soit pas assez mais
monsieur monsieur baba de même faire le
début de la pandémie
il a été présenté après nous on après
que madame madame makan soit acquitté
comme le maillon faible du gouvernement
vous lui avez dit combien noël vous
faites vous de guano elle très fort je
pense que c'était georges et je vous
présente en attendant il reste plus
beaucoup ta josée legault
non ça fait ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on
observe oui en effet une brique
confiance entre les mines et ses deux
milieux de l'éducation il ya énormément
de retard qui se prend et la critique
qu'on entend le plus c'est que lorsque
vient le temps d'agir nommé ni ses trous
là donc est-ce qu'il est trop l'air
parce qu'il est trop lent ou est-ce
qu'il est trop là parce que il ya des
difficultés à convaincre le conseil des
ministres son premier ministre de poser
certains gestes ont commencé à la
ventilation par exemple mais il ya un
problème c'est que martine ce qu'on
entend beaucoup à québec c'est que c'est
un ministre qui travaillent seuls en
vase clos qui colle à bois qui n'est pas
très collégial
alors c'est depuis le début du mandat
que c'est difficile avec ses propres
clientèle ce sont eux qui abolit les
commissions scolaires alors s'est dit
fier de collaborer avec eux la pandémie
ça s'est pas améliorée monsieur legault
lui a donné une chance au printemps
il ya encore beaucoup de difficultés que
c'était bien c'est moi et michel on dit
à l'oreille on a vérifié dans votre
petit vous avez laissé moins j'avais une
bonne mémoire
merci à vous trois mois j'ai en tête ces
gens qui attendent sur 10 laissant voir
parler au cours des prochains jours
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été là on
va voir
[Musique]
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit